David: The cloud great.
David: and I've started recording, I'd like to confirm. Are you comfortable if I record the screen and audio as we speak today.
Megan Zehnder: Yes.
David: Great, great, great, great.
David: Okay? So let's just kind of jump into it. Can you tell me a little bit about your role at the Va.
Megan Zehnder: Yes, so I work with the Cms pretty extensively. I am on a content.
Megan Zehnder: I'm I work on the Content side as a copy editor. So I work on a lot of the static pages so like any of the pages on Va. Gov. That people don't have to be authenticated to get into. Those are mostly the pages that we work on.
Megan Zehnder: Which
Megan Zehnder: many are on drupal. And
Megan Zehnder: we don't work with a ton of images regularly. On the like core benefit pages and
Megan Zehnder: resources and support pages that that we often are
Megan Zehnder: creating or editing or updating.
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: yeah, that's a little bit about my
Megan Zehnder: interactions with drupal.
Megan Zehnder: But we work kind of across
Megan Zehnder: lots of work with lots of teams, product teams and business lines. Any anything that kind of touches the
Megan Zehnder: content on va.gov.
David: Got it. So you said you don't often work with images, are there
David: when you do work with images. Are there specific pages that you're working on more than others? Or is it kind of whatever comes up.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. So I would say, it's not. It's like, not our standard. But there are occasionally times like, for instance, in the last week.
Megan Zehnder: when we put together a step by step
Megan Zehnder: process page that was this was in like the resources and support section of the site, which is where there are a lot of like questions and answers. That come up. This particular one was
Megan Zehnder: advising people on how to sign in and how to verify their account. And so there were a lot of screenshots involved. And so that was the main way that I was using the
Megan Zehnder: the upload image tool for that one.
Megan Zehnder: but it is a little bit more rare. But but
Megan Zehnder: you know, when we do use it.
Megan Zehnder: it's probably it's usually on pages that
Megan Zehnder: probably, you know, have a lot of traffic or or
Megan Zehnder: for whatever reason.
Megan Zehnder: lend itself to needing imagery.
David: Got it. Got it. So these are. It's not
David: so much on like an event or a story page, or it's more like instructional
David: lots of pictures. Got it. Okay.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, more.
David: And
David: So generally, when you're receiving an image, or when you're like preparing an image for this, do you find yourself editing and cropping it beforehand or yeah, do you? Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: Yes, yes, so
Megan Zehnder: definitely
Megan Zehnder: cropping, at least in this instance. Last week.
Megan Zehnder: we kind of had to to
Megan Zehnder: crop them and get them and
Megan Zehnder: process them so that to try and get them consistent.
Megan Zehnder: a little bit more new at that process. And you know my background is more in content than I. I
Megan Zehnder: I struggled a bit with that process. But
Megan Zehnder: yes, in the rare instances that I have worked with
Megan Zehnder: images.
Megan Zehnder: I've done the processing and resizing
Megan Zehnder: before uploading.
David: Got it.
David: And that is the main goal for that to have just consistency. Or is there like
David: upload
David: problems or things that you're also trying to avoid
David: sizing. I don't know.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, it's for consistency.
David: It's for consistency. Got it? Yeah.
David: okay.
David: great and do you find yourself using images from the media library as well? Or are you really just uploading new images as you need them?
Megan Zehnder: So for this instance, I did
Megan Zehnder: go back into the media library because I want it, like.
Megan Zehnder: for a couple of reasons, mostly to adjust all the alt text later, or to re upload a different size image because the 1st one didn't work out when I previewed it. So I went back into the media library, not so much to like see what was available, but more to
Megan Zehnder: revisit
Megan Zehnder: images that I already uploaded.
David: Revisit images you've already uploaded, and you mentioned kind of like when it's
David: when you see the image like in the preview. Then, you know it's good or not.
David: is this, this is at at what point in your workflow is this.
Megan Zehnder: So
Megan Zehnder: this is probably like
Megan Zehnder: kind of in the middle of the workflow, like I, or toward the end, possibly
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: like as I'm uploading images and trying to see
Megan Zehnder: how it's looking. I might test a different size to see how that works.
David: But.
Megan Zehnder: Maybe, like, for the most part, it's toward the end, when I'm trying to make everything consistent. And I might need to make adjustments to the photo or to the alt text.
Megan Zehnder: like, after everything else is in place.
David: I see.
David: Okay, great. So we'll jump into our 1st task. Now.
David: if you could open your Cms
David: and share your screen, that would be great and feel free to like log in or anything before you start sharing. If if you, if you want.
Megan Zehnder: Already. In. So let me.
David: Perkin.
Megan Zehnder: Be able to.
David: Receive.
Megan Zehnder: The Cms.
David: Yeah, I see it. That's perfect.
David: So I'm really curious about like the page that you said you were kind of working on right now.
David: And
David: maybe if you could show me how you you could either go to the original, the one that you're working on and show me kind of there, or if it'd be easier to do a new one, just to kind of see that process.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I can. This.
Megan Zehnder: I can show you the one that I was working on.
David: Step by step, got it.
Megan Zehnder: Step by step. Yeah, template. And
Megan Zehnder: we added.
Megan Zehnder: do you want to see the preview or the edit mode?
David: this I mean, yeah, this is what I'm I'm very interested in, just like this part. So the step by step, you're you're uploading these images to it.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: And there were
Megan Zehnder: maybe like 2 editors in here, maybe 2 or 3. So at various points we were both adding images.
Megan Zehnder: So
Megan Zehnder: that's just another
Megan Zehnder: character. But
Megan Zehnder: there were many, and I went back to
Megan Zehnder: The
Megan Zehnder: I ended up. Sorry if I was scrolling. I ended up going back into the media library like several times, just to
Megan Zehnder: make sure that
Megan Zehnder: just to adjust the image size or to adjust the Alt text.
Megan Zehnder: Hmm.
David: Huh?
David: So I have
David: a couple of questions for you. The 1st is.
David: and what does consistency
David: mean to you? Is it like the same width size.
David: Is it something.
Megan Zehnder: Announce.
Megan Zehnder: So for this one.
Megan Zehnder: we're gonna probably revisit these images, or we're definitely revisiting them because they I'm still not happy with
Megan Zehnder: the resolution. I think it looks really pixelated.
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: or like the v 1, just to get this out because it was a little bit of a time. Crunch! We
Megan Zehnder: just went with these images and
Megan Zehnder: got them all
Megan Zehnder: in
Megan Zehnder: The consistency that we were looking for in this instance was like a consistent width.
Megan Zehnder: So I think we were able to generally
Megan Zehnder: achieve that.
Megan Zehnder: But again, like it's this is not perfect. And
Megan Zehnder: ideally.
Megan Zehnder: we would want these to have a better resolution.
Megan Zehnder: I think I don't know. I'm talking with the designer tomorrow to kind of get their perspective on
Megan Zehnder: how to
Megan Zehnder: make this better. But.
David: I see.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: Okay, that's great. Now, if you go back to that, I think the 1st tab. Yeah.
David: There's 1
David: I was hoping you could just
David: before like not saving it, but kind of walk me through your process of uploading an image. I think there's
David: one or 2 that don't have an image that maybe we could practice on.
Megan Zehnder: Sure.
Megan Zehnder: yeah, I guess I could add it.
Megan Zehnder: or maybe, should I just start? Maybe I'll start a new one. Just so I don't want to get.
David: Oh, yeah, whatever is easier or safer.
Megan Zehnder: Let me just start a new one, just
Megan Zehnder: in case someone needs to go into that post or something.
David: Absolutely.
Megan Zehnder: next up
Megan Zehnder: and
Megan Zehnder: so
Megan Zehnder: do you want to see my process, for, like how I resize them.
David: You can show that to me I'd be I yeah, I mean, whatever you'd like to show me, I I as you do your typical flow of an image.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, it definitely changed as I was working on this post, because
Megan Zehnder: at 1st I was just uploading them, kind of like as they were given to me. So.
Megan Zehnder: I had my
Megan Zehnder: sorry. This looks really disorganized because it was
Megan Zehnder: a quick process, but
Megan Zehnder: like I had my images that I was given, and then I
Megan Zehnder: added them.
Megan Zehnder: I added description
Megan Zehnder: like
Megan Zehnder: something like that.
Megan Zehnder: And then
Megan Zehnder: section. This was kind of annoying to scroll through. Why, but
Megan Zehnder: not going there.
Megan Zehnder: And then I I still I tried to make this a little bit different.
David: Yeah, what? I'm curious. What's the difference between the description and the alt text?
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. Well, I tried to.
Megan Zehnder: My, you know, from my understanding.
Megan Zehnder: tried to make all text a little bit more
Megan Zehnder: descriptive.
Megan Zehnder: And use this a little bit more as like
Megan Zehnder: the title
Megan Zehnder: but I don't have high confidence in how I was filling these out so.
David: And then I'm curious also about the sections.
David: You mentioned. It was a little bit.
David: I think he used the word frustrating or.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, it just was like, I don't know what were the issues. I think that like, I would
Megan Zehnder: try and go down here.
Megan Zehnder: And then sometimes it would flip back up.
Megan Zehnder: not. I don't seem to be having that issue right now.
David: Okay. But there's there's a lot to kind of scroll through.
Megan Zehnder: For me. There is. Yeah, I don't know if everyone has the same view, but it
Megan Zehnder: it is a lot. Yeah.
David: Yeah.
David: is this the same? Is this the same view you typically have when you are selecting sections
David: in other places.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I think it is when we're when we're creating a new page. Then I I'm pretty sure it is. I can go and check. But
Megan Zehnder: yeah.
Megan Zehnder: And then, okay, so
Megan Zehnder: did that
Megan Zehnder: step one?
Megan Zehnder: Oh, I know something that was really frustrating.
Megan Zehnder: was
Megan Zehnder: I so in in the
Megan Zehnder: the image that I was adding like, sometimes I wanted to describe like.
Megan Zehnder: step one
Megan Zehnder: upload and upload
Megan Zehnder: an image of your Id, because that's what the picture was of, and I I couldn't do it because it had
Megan Zehnder: image of which I understand. Why that
Megan Zehnder: like? Why.
David: Oh, that's so interesting. Yeah, cause you're not using it as saying, this is an image of this. You're using it.
Megan Zehnder: Right, exactly so.
David: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: For me. This was
Megan Zehnder: this was a problem.
Megan Zehnder: but you know I don't know how many times people are uploading images in this way. But I had to like
Megan Zehnder: I don't even know what I ended up doing, but I was like.
Megan Zehnder: upload
Megan Zehnder: your id or something. I don't. I don't know how I ended up wording it, but I had to.
Megan Zehnder: I had to really do some some results around that copy.
David: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: Okay? And then I.
David: So I'm just curious about those cropping options. Are are you using any of those.
Megan Zehnder: Oh, are there cropping options.
David: Oh, yeah, no. That that. Okay. Now that.
Megan Zehnder: How do I? Okay, let me go back. And then can I let me
Megan Zehnder: look in the
Megan Zehnder: go back to the media library?
Megan Zehnder: My gosh, if I miss the crafting options completely.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, media.
Megan Zehnder: so I just did. Okay.
Megan Zehnder: Oh, this. Oh, big, these cropping images. Yeah, okay, so I did see these.
Megan Zehnder: I didn't know how
Megan Zehnder: to use this in a way that would be that would help me get consistency with all the other images, because all the other images
Megan Zehnder: we're coming from
Megan Zehnder: slightly different places. Maybe I should have thought about this a little differently. But
Megan Zehnder: yeah.
David: I I hear what you're saying. It's.
Megan Zehnder: Was not.
David: Not allowing you to
David: do something that's like consistent. Besides, it's like it's visual
David: cropping versus.
Megan Zehnder: Resizing right like I couldn't. I needed to resize. I think I it wasn't that I needed to crop. Necessarily, I needed to resize.
David: I see.
Megan Zehnder: So maybe there's a way to do this. But I didn't.
Megan Zehnder: I did not.
Megan Zehnder: I did not mess with it. I didn't. I didn't explore it.
Megan Zehnder: Instead, I used
Megan Zehnder: an outside program.
Megan Zehnder: I just use canva.
David: Canva. Okay? Yeah, I've I've heard that canvas very commonly used. So that's good.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. And I I'll say that I struggled a lot with that because
Megan Zehnder: because I originally, we like
Megan Zehnder: put these in a word, Doc, and and
Megan Zehnder: tried to make them consistent in the word doc
Megan Zehnder: by adjusting their inches. So like we made all the images
Megan Zehnder: 2 and a half inches, or whatever.
Megan Zehnder: But then, for whatever reason, when we uploaded them in here.
Megan Zehnder: the
Megan Zehnder: the pixels were all different, so the images displayed
Megan Zehnder: in all different sizes.
Megan Zehnder: So
Megan Zehnder: so the adjustment that we made in the word Doc to adjust the the inches did not work. So what I ended up doing was
Megan Zehnder: uploading them all in canva.
Megan Zehnder: adjusting
Megan Zehnder: the image, sorry, adjusting the inches.
Megan Zehnder: and then like matching that with the pixels and sizing it that way. And I'm probably using this terminology all wrong, because I'm not a designer. But
Megan Zehnder: but there was something about like the inches and pixels
Megan Zehnder: that for whatever reason, the 1st round were not
Megan Zehnder: scaling together. And I had to try and like
Megan Zehnder: figure it out in canva.
David: Got it. Got it.
Megan Zehnder: You may.
David: Okay? And if we scroll down just a bit. So you typically
David: don't select any of these cropping options, you just kind of
David: go keep going.
Megan Zehnder: I I have not. I can imagine, though, if I like, had an image, and I just needed a little part of it. Maybe I would
Megan Zehnder: use this.
Megan Zehnder: But I would say like, this is a little bit not
Megan Zehnder: clear to me like what this part.
Megan Zehnder: what the ratios mean.
David: Okay.
David: and then
David: I know we're on kind of like the the image thing itself.
David: but if we were back on the page that we were on before, where we were like uploading the image. You had 2 options insert and select and insert.
David: or save and save and select and save and insert.
David: and I'm curious.
David: Which one you.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, let me go back to that page.
Megan Zehnder: hold on
Megan Zehnder: November
Megan Zehnder: test.
Megan Zehnder: He's gonna
Megan Zehnder: hmm
Megan Zehnder: know how I got back to that page.
Megan Zehnder: Hold on
Megan Zehnder: instead.
David: Oh, maybe didn't! Oh.
Megan Zehnder: Did I not save it?
David: Yeah, maybe we didn't save the page.
Megan Zehnder: And then I just exited out of it. Suddenly.
David: There's a
David: is it, Champ? I I don't know.
Megan Zehnder: Well, okay, let me go back into this page.
Megan Zehnder: and I'll
Megan Zehnder: I can try them.
Megan Zehnder: Okay. So I did my description.
Megan Zehnder: It does
Megan Zehnder: on my.
Megan Zehnder: I'll text
David: A couple of questions. Actually, do you ever find yourself unchecking the reusable.
Megan Zehnder: I don't.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
David: And then
David: my other question is, Yeah, what's the difference between save and select and save and insert.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know, I guess, save and insert. It goes right into the the post right away. But I did not
Megan Zehnder: really. I did not
Megan Zehnder: think about these very intentionally. I just went with the one that was selected.
David: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: Great, great, great, great.
David: Okay, though
David: overall.
David: How? How was that experience for you filling this out.
Megan Zehnder: I mean, outside of, like the
Megan Zehnder: massive problems I had with trying to get a consistent
Megan Zehnder: like width or image of my source images.
Megan Zehnder: So maybe that's like out of scope, out of scope on a different issue.
Megan Zehnder: This was.
Megan Zehnder: it wasn't like a horrible experience like I was able to go
Megan Zehnder: into the
Megan Zehnder: media library
Megan Zehnder: pretty easily.
Megan Zehnder: and find the image.
Megan Zehnder: yeah, I wouldn't say that like
Megan Zehnder: this
Megan Zehnder: felt very useful to me, like in in its current iteration.
Megan Zehnder: it's a cute one.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, you get one.
David: Curious.
David: When do you think something like this would be valuable.
David: or could it be.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah,
Megan Zehnder: I guess if you're trying to like
Megan Zehnder: if you have a huge screenshot, and you're like, I just want this part.
Megan Zehnder: So I'm gonna
Megan Zehnder: but like, why is it?
Megan Zehnder: Why does it seem like I can
Megan Zehnder: adjust it? But then I can't.
David: Yeah, I'm not sure about that one.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. But I guess, like, if you're if you just have a large image and you're trying to.
Megan Zehnder: and you don't feel comfortable. And outside
Megan Zehnder: editing software. Then
Megan Zehnder: then they're like, it is
Megan Zehnder: nice to have at least some
Megan Zehnder: way to edit the photo in this tool.
David: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: But it is.
Megan Zehnder: It's a little tricky. Oh, I guess. Okay, that's when you do preform.
Megan Zehnder: Great. Oh.
David: Okay. So now.
David: I'm gonna shift us to our next part of this, where I'm gonna send you
David: a prototype that we're working on.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
David: So I'm gonna go ahead and just share it in chat.
David: And we're gonna do probably a little bit of pretending here. So the prototype that we have is for events.
David: It's
David: There are the the module for the actual like image uploader is the same. This is just kind of an event. Situation? So there are certain things that are
David: the same, certain things that are different than your workflow. But yeah, hopefully, we can.
David: And I got through that
David: and let's go into the left nav. There's like a proposed flow and a current flow. Let's do the proposed flow.
David: And then what I'd
David: like you do is imagine that you've started to create a new event for veterans.
David: Okay, you've entered the date and time.
David: Which va location. It's going to be
David: happening at. And now it's time to upload that image.
David: So yeah, I'd like for you to show me how you would go ahead and do that.
Megan Zehnder: I say, I have my image ready.
David: Yeah. And it, it's kind of baked into this. So you can't really drag and drop. But like, if you do the things that you would normally do. You'll see
David: the more problem.
Megan Zehnder: Okay. You want me to keep going.
David: Yep. Yep.
Megan Zehnder: Nice.
Megan Zehnder: Okay? So all they all have to be the same aspect. Ratio.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
David: And that that's an events, thing.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, so that's
Megan Zehnder: got it. That makes sense. Okay.
Megan Zehnder: yes.
Megan Zehnder: What would I do if I was like, oh, wait! I actually don't like where that
Megan Zehnder: like, how I edit, how I adjusted that!
Megan Zehnder: Is there
Megan Zehnder: something I can do to
Megan Zehnder: go back.
David: Yeah. What do you? What do you think?
David: What would you like.
Megan Zehnder: I guess I would.
Megan Zehnder: maybe finish editing this and go back
Megan Zehnder: to the media library to see if I can like readjust that or something.
David: Okay, you would go back to the media library to readjust that.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: or but if there was like a
Megan Zehnder: little edit icon or something, then I would
Megan Zehnder: click on that to try and get back to the edit screen.
David: Gotcha, and what would happen if you pressed X.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know.
Megan Zehnder: Oh, and go away. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay.
Megan Zehnder: then I would just re upload it.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, yeah, that that makes sense.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: Yeah, that part's not gonna work.
Megan Zehnder: Thank you.
Megan Zehnder: But okay, so I could adjust it. There, continue.
Megan Zehnder: Add my Alt text.
Megan Zehnder: adjust, file, name.
Megan Zehnder: and I could remove it here and then.
David: You can click that.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, that feels right?
David: Would would
David: editing at this stage.
David: So so I guess. Actually let me take a step back. You
David: seemed a little hesitant, I think, with clicking that X
David: was. That was that for a reason.
David: Perfect.
David: or did he not? Did you notice it? Did you notice the act.
Megan Zehnder: I did notice it, and I.
David: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: I think, like my hesitation
Megan Zehnder: in pressing. That was that
Megan Zehnder: I wasn't necessarily ready to like, scrap everything and go back and find my image. I just wanted to like. Readjust it again.
Megan Zehnder: so
Megan Zehnder: like I just wanted to go one step back versus like
Megan Zehnder: 2 or 3. But it wasn't a bad experience I probably like. If I was unhappy with that.
Megan Zehnder: I think
Megan Zehnder: I would probably just start over, and
Megan Zehnder: you know, whatever.
David: I see, but it would be nicer to just go one step back rather than
David: the work you put in kind of being.
Megan Zehnder: Right? Yeah, to like find the image and upload it.
David: I see.
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: I think overall it was clean and easy, and
Megan Zehnder: it was a lot less like
Megan Zehnder: there was a lot less that was unclear.
Megan Zehnder: It was a pretty simple process, and I could like adjust it right away.
Megan Zehnder: So I like that part.
David: yeah, what's so yeah, you're kind of getting into this what stands out to you about this newer
David: update design.
Megan Zehnder: I think that there are fewer options which could be good in certain situations, and maybe
Megan Zehnder: not ideal in all situations.
Megan Zehnder: but like.
Megan Zehnder: I think, having like the one image ratio for
Megan Zehnder: certain templated
Megan Zehnder: spots is great because
Megan Zehnder: it just
Megan Zehnder: it just helps cut out a
Megan Zehnder: something to think about.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know. Can I go back to like in the
Megan Zehnder: to to just see what my options are if I upload it? And I realize like, oh, this looks way, too
Megan Zehnder: like the.
David: So.
Megan Zehnder: What work for this one.
David: Yeah, you can go back. You can use. So I have a current flow which is the exact
David: thing for the events right now, or you can go into the Cms and check it out yourself. Whatever is easiest.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, I think I just wanted to go. Yeah, this one. Okay. So okay, so I have this.
Megan Zehnder: and I select this
Megan Zehnder: So if I have an event that like this, ratio doesn't work, and I need to get like I need to change my
Megan Zehnder: image. I guess I just go back
Megan Zehnder: and
Megan Zehnder: take a new image, and that's what I would do.
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: I wonder if there should be
Megan Zehnder: Wonder if there's like any text that would be helpful. That's like
Megan Zehnder: what to do if like this.
Megan Zehnder: If the crop
Megan Zehnder: cropping tool doesn't
Megan Zehnder: is cutting off certain parts of your
Megan Zehnder: image.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know. Maybe it's intuitive, though, that you just
Megan Zehnder: I think what I would do personally is I would just say, Okay, this is not gonna work.
Megan Zehnder: the image. The source image doesn't work for what I need. So I need to go and figure out something else. I need to get a new one.
David: Yeah. If you go ahead and press back.
David: I'm curious if you
David: saw those recommended image size the bullets up top.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, that is
Megan Zehnder: important to have. But I I would probably
Megan Zehnder: like.
Megan Zehnder: try what I have first.st And I and like, learn through the visual.
Megan Zehnder: But
Megan Zehnder: yeah, so I don't. I don't know that it necessarily needs to be repeated in here.
Megan Zehnder: yeah. So may actually, yeah, maybe. Then I go back and say, Okay.
Megan Zehnder: 1954.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: So I'm wondering
David: in your workflow if you, if you go ahead and press, cancel here.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
David: Do you have your you? Do you have your image prepared
David: before you click.
David: add media, upload image, whatever it is.
David: Or are you kind of like clicking it, and then slowly gathering your
David: information, gathering your photos.
Megan Zehnder: Well, I think I
Megan Zehnder: ideally, I'd have everything ready. But I think there's it's just harder to know how it's gonna look
Megan Zehnder: in production until I can upload it and preview it. So there's just naturally going to be
Megan Zehnder: some like readjusting at that phase like.
David: You know.
Megan Zehnder: Even if I
Megan Zehnder: have all the images, and they're like all the right size.
Megan Zehnder: And I upload it. And I'm like, Oh, actually, like, I have the right size, but, like the main thing that I want is up here.
Megan Zehnder: So I'm gonna need to like rethink that and
Megan Zehnder: resize it, or something.
David: Got it.
Megan Zehnder: I think. I think this like is very helpful that it.
Megan Zehnder: you know it shows what part is going to be seen.
Megan Zehnder: And it's very clear, like
Megan Zehnder: what part is not going to be seen. So
Megan Zehnder: it's as like someone using this. It's so much more helpful to to get the preview. And
Megan Zehnder: see, get a, you know. Get a sense of what's going to be cropped
Megan Zehnder: at this phase rather than like as you're previewing it.
Megan Zehnder: Oh.
David: Okay. So you are saving
David: like a little bit of a few clicks by not having to like press preview. You're already getting.
Megan Zehnder: Right.
David: That preview. Okay.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: And that, and that's and that's helpful for you, and.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I think it's really helpful to see
Megan Zehnder: what is gonna get cropped out and what what will be
Megan Zehnder: in the
Megan Zehnder: in the post or in the page.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Now, if you go ahead and click continue. I have a couple of other questions for you. One thing is.
David: I'm not even sure if you noticed that
David: this version removes description.
David: Field.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, that is nice.
David: That is nice. You like that.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I think that
Megan Zehnder: that saves some time for me to figure out what I'm supposed, how I'm supposed to differentiate them.
Megan Zehnder: Hi.
Megan Zehnder: one thing.
Megan Zehnder: 2 like
Megan Zehnder: this might be a little bit of an aside, but
Megan Zehnder: I noticed in the current iteration, when I remove the image, the Alt text also gets removed.
Megan Zehnder: and that was a little bit of a frustrating point, because
Megan Zehnder: I had to go back and like I had to recreate it each time. If I didn't remember to save in advance.
Megan Zehnder: because when I remove the image
Megan Zehnder: like sometimes I just replaced it with a different size and
Megan Zehnder: and so like the Alt text.
Megan Zehnder: you know
Megan Zehnder: I want. I wanted it to remain the same.
David: And just.
Megan Zehnder: If we deleted it once I press remove
Megan Zehnder: so
Megan Zehnder: I don't know. Maybe like, if these 2 settings could stay like, I understand that
Megan Zehnder: the different file name. But
Megan Zehnder: that was just
Megan Zehnder: something I remembered.
David: Yeah.
David: yeah, that's interesting. So you'll you typically will enter in just as I'm like on the same page. You'll enter in your all text your section.
David: then. But the ish, I guess the difference is in the current version you're leaving. You're saving. You're committing.
David: Yeah? Then you're gonna go see? The preview.
Megan Zehnder: Right then I'm gonna go see the preview. And then I typically like multiple times in that last page I was working on, I would actually remove this, and I would re upload a different image that I had processed differently, and
Megan Zehnder: that I wanted to work with. And then I had to like, re-enter everything again
Megan Zehnder: which was annoying. Right.
David: I see. Yeah, now, does this process of like having the image here still like that is being cropped and like kind of giving you a more one to one preview. What you'll be seeing does that support
David: like your workflow still? Is that making it any easier.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I think it's really helpful to see
Megan Zehnder: how it's going to be cropped in this way. Yeah, I think this is helpful.
David: Great.
David: great, great, great
David: so are there any additional improvements or things you'd like to see in this prototype things that would make
David: your life easier
David: when uploading photos or images.
Megan Zehnder: If this was my main.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, I think like.
Megan Zehnder: if if
Megan Zehnder: the content types that are working on only allowed for this
Megan Zehnder: aspect ratio
Megan Zehnder: Then this would be great, and it would feel easy, and it.
David: Now let's talk about
David: your step by step. Pages. I know this is just it's kind of different.
David: But
David: what
David: would you like to see in this, to make your step by step pages
David: image uploading a little bit easier.
Megan Zehnder: So I think a couple of things also, before I answer, Can I can. I just ask one more thing that I noticed?
Megan Zehnder: So this one out of one image uploaded?
Megan Zehnder: I don't totally know.
Megan Zehnder: Like, was there a spot where I could add more than one
Megan Zehnder: you're like? I guess I'm confused by seeing that text
Megan Zehnder: like what it
Megan Zehnder: what it means, cause I I didn't see anywhere in the flow
Megan Zehnder: place to add more than one.
David: Yeah, for event images. They require only one image. You can't put 2
David: or anything like that. Other pages might.
David: I think, have
David: several options in a single upload. But what what do you? What do you think?
David: Tell me more about why you're bringing this up? Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: I would just expect to see image uploaded. Checkmark.
Megan Zehnder: Oh.
David: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: I wouldn't.
Megan Zehnder: I think the one out of one
Megan Zehnder: just
Megan Zehnder: makes me confused about like if there is another
Megan Zehnder: place to add one or or
Megan Zehnder: like. Why it's
Megan Zehnder: but again, I'm not the
Megan Zehnder: maybe maybe for someone. It is meaningful because they don't know if they're supposed to add one or not.
Megan Zehnder: One
Megan Zehnder: so I don't know how.
David: You don't know how that one of one yeah, where it's.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
Megan Zehnder: yeah, right.
David: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: For someone else. It would make more sense. But.
David: So I'm curious now, like, if you had a magic wand right, you can wave it around and make yourself
David: the perfect
David: image uploader.
David: not for events, but for the work that you're working on.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah.
David: What might you
David: do?
Megan Zehnder: So.
Megan Zehnder: I mean the one I think one minor thing is just
Megan Zehnder: not deleting that
Megan Zehnder: alternate text. When I remove an image going back into
Megan Zehnder: like the same settings and a
Megan Zehnder: the media library. That's just a minor one.
Megan Zehnder: I
Megan Zehnder: go to the current flow.
Megan Zehnder: So is this.
Megan Zehnder: this is like.
Megan Zehnder: okay, yeah. This one.
Megan Zehnder: I feel like being able to
Megan Zehnder: like. If if I could see the full size, see? I don't. I don't know exactly what what would have made it easier in my.
Megan Zehnder: The page that I was working on
Megan Zehnder: like what I was looking for is some kind of like visual
Megan Zehnder: drag or drop like I guess I probably didn't go far enough in these
Megan Zehnder: or like resizing.
Megan Zehnder: But what I what was helpful for me in canva
Megan Zehnder: in the end was being able to.
Megan Zehnder: Oh, this is, we're almost done in 2min.
Megan Zehnder: being able.
David: So I'm.
Megan Zehnder: Okay. Yeah.
David: Yeah, I'm okay. I'm here.
Megan Zehnder: Okay, cool and
Megan Zehnder: no, I'm rambling a bit.
Megan Zehnder: but I just wanted to like pull up what was useful for me in canva. And then.
David: Yeah, no, that'd be great to see.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: New.
Megan Zehnder: You can see my canva.
David: Yes, I can.
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
Megan Zehnder: all these pages that I was trying to work on.
Megan Zehnder: okay.
Megan Zehnder: So
Megan Zehnder: what I ended up doing was like looking at these inches and pixels, which.
Megan Zehnder: like maybe it would be helpful when I uploaded it. If if
Megan Zehnder: drupal would tell me like
Megan Zehnder: what the size is and what the what the width is like, either in pixels or inches, or something, so that I can.
Megan Zehnder: if I can.
Megan Zehnder: adjust it
Megan Zehnder: in drupal, and I can like see the numbers. Then I can see like, Oh, that is, that number is off like, if I if I saw when I uploaded it like, okay, this is 500 pixels by 1,800, and then the other. The next time I I
Megan Zehnder: upload another one it was like 1,800 pixels by 600. Then I could like tell that
Megan Zehnder: some things are off off because one is 501 is 1,800.
Megan Zehnder: So if I had some kind of like
Megan Zehnder: visual cue
Megan Zehnder: of
Megan Zehnder: the size that was uploading.
Megan Zehnder: I think it would be really helpful. And then.
Megan Zehnder: if there was a way
Megan Zehnder: to like, adjust it in there and just say, Okay, crop this down. And even if it scales it so it's not like
Megan Zehnder: cutting it off, but then scaling it to.
Megan Zehnder: it's like, no, I actually don't want this to be 2.7. I want I want to be 5 or whatever, and then upload that
Megan Zehnder: that would be really helpful. I you know that that and that's magic. Wand Ish, because
Megan Zehnder: I know that's like a lot, and we're not a
Megan Zehnder: image editing tool. But
Megan Zehnder: I just felt like I was uploading these, and I had no sense of like how I could even adjust it to to create a consistent like
Megan Zehnder: pixel width size.
Megan Zehnder: So
Megan Zehnder: anyway, that's what was, that's what was frustrating. But
Megan Zehnder: it. I eventually
Megan Zehnder: figured it out.
David: Thank you so much for sharing the canva. I think that's a really helpful
David: representation of how you're going through the flow currently and
David: well, definitely
David: talk about ways to, you know.
David: bridge that gap a little bit more. We do have a couple of questions from the group.
David: I'll read them out. But yeah, if any of the observers want to like, add, or or clarify anything, feel free to jump in christian asks in your current flow. Are you viewing the node to preview the image as opposed to reviewing the image only in the uploader model model
David: modal.
Megan Zehnder: Yes. So when I look at the
Megan Zehnder: the
Megan Zehnder: node, I'm doing the standard Cms preview, so that I see all of them
Megan Zehnder: once they're added.
Megan Zehnder: is that what you mean?
Megan Zehnder: Okay.
Christian Burk (Omaha, Nebr.): Yeah, that's what I was thinking. Thank you. Appreciate it.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah, definitely use the preview heavily.
David: Perfect and then we have another question from Megan in your current flow.
David: Did you upload images all at once in the media library? Or do you go one by one, as you go through each step.
Megan Zehnder: In this last instance I was.
Megan Zehnder: I did a little bit of both. I started adding them all at once, and then, when I realized
Megan Zehnder: this was not consistent.
Megan Zehnder: I kind of paused on that approach
Megan Zehnder: finish, getting all the content that I needed ready. And then
Megan Zehnder: and then just tried to figure out the image issue separately.
Megan Commons: Yeah. Cause I'm even thinking if you were going one by one like
Megan Commons: uploading them all at once would be even more work. Because then again, okay, let's re upload everything. Now that we got that. And that would, okay, okay.
Megan Zehnder: It was a lot of that.
Megan Commons: I believe it.
Megan Zehnder: I was not efficient, because I was just struggling a lot with the
Megan Zehnder: with my, you know, design ignorance. But it was
Megan Zehnder: yeah, I think like after I realized it was not being consistent. Then I tried to just shift my attention
Megan Zehnder: at the end.
Megan Commons: Okay.
Megan Commons: yeah. Did you ever
Megan Commons: cause you, you talked about how you go back to the media library to edit things.
Megan Commons: So we're you like back and forth a lot between. Okay media library to edit.
Megan Commons: re upload media library to edit, re upload, like, I guess how. What was
Megan Commons: kind of the.
Megan Zehnder: Well, okay. So there were 2 editors, so like the 1st editor who added images added them, and they were like all over the place. So then I tried to. I went back
Megan Zehnder: and into the media library and tried to adjust it from there, but I was only adjusting the inches, and it didn't. And I was like, I'm I'm
Megan Zehnder: I kept thinking I was like uploading the same image, but it was like a totally different pixel size.
Megan Commons: Yeah, yeah.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know what really speak to that part, but so anyway, that at that
Megan Zehnder: point I was going back and forth a lot to try and troubleshoot.
Megan Zehnder: And then
Megan Zehnder: toward the end, once I figured it out, I just was going back in and re uploading for all of them to try and get them consistent.
Megan Commons: Okay. Cool.
Megan Zehnder: Makes sense. Yeah.
David: Yeah. I'm
David: have a couple like 1. 1 more question. If that's okay, are you? Okay on time? Okay?
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. Totally. Yeah.
David: are there? And then this is this is a question. Beyond, just like events and uploading images.
David: Is there anything else within the drupal cms that you'd like
David: to be.
David: that that might be like more difficult than it should be, or might cause more frustration that we can keep in our backlog and our list of like. Oh, these are things that we could eventually get to, to make your lives easier as a editors.
Megan Zehnder: Checking links is
Megan Zehnder: portable.
David: Gaining, link.
Megan Zehnder: Yes.
Megan Zehnder: there's like.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know right now. We have these link sees that are making up the flow really hard to check links
Megan Zehnder: in preview mode
Megan Zehnder: links don't really work. So then you have to look at it in view mode in the drupal.
Megan Zehnder: and
Megan Zehnder: and it's just
Megan Zehnder: harder than it should be.
David: Anything else.
Megan Zehnder: I am sure. Can I? Can I follow up on that.
David: Yeah, like, if there's anything else that comes up, love to
David: hear it. Yeah, we're we're kind of compiling a little bit of a list here, too, like after this, what? What else we could eventually hit. So
David: yeah, that's.
Megan Zehnder: Oh!
David: Great.
Megan Zehnder: Thanks for letting me share all this. It's really nice to
Megan Zehnder: to like. Explain.
Megan Zehnder: I don't know. Just talk about it, cause it was a
Megan Zehnder: I. I'm so glad that I used the tool and like, and finally got it. That was really
Megan Zehnder: satisfying. But it yeah, and I don't know if any of the
Megan Zehnder: problems I went into were helpful at all. But it was helpful for me.
David: Incredibly helpful. Really, really like, appreciate your time, appreciate your thoughtful answers. And yeah, thanks again.
Megan Zehnder: Yeah. Good luck with this project. Thanks for tackling this. Really appreciate it.
Megan Commons: Nice to meet you. Thanks, Megan.
Megan Zehnder: You, too, talk to you later. Bye.